Hello america it's been a long time since i
donned the old secret identity but trust me
it's me homelander now look there's been a little
drama around vaught of lake but i want to reassure
you here and now superheroes are still the good
guys we're not perfect i mean i've ran through a
girl but only because she stepped off the curb
and into the middle of the street like a crazy
person but we all make mistakes and that's
why pencils have erasers right i want to go
ahead and apologize for a trains comments but the
point is being a superhero is about saving lives
being an inspiration and rescuing the
dolphins you won't leave alone actually
what i was going to say was that okay are we
uh are we going okay hey um so did a train
just say that killing robin is why pencils
have erasers uh yeah that's pretty [ __ ] up
sorry for the interruption okay i wasn't
finished the thing we need to focus on
is making america safe again and the only way
to do that is more superheroes oh hi there as
a member of the church of the collective i can
assure you there's a larger plan for all of us
and if you enroll in our church classes for
the low price of seventeen hundred dollars
each we'll tell you what that plan is but the
point is there's absolutely nothing to fear
we got photos of that dude with a
manatee but you're gonna listen to him
there is a new wave of soup terrorists and we are
the only ones who can stop them that's why going
back to my previous point superheroes are about
murder if you look at them wrong they will kill
you what he's trying to say is that soups are
bad okay i mean except for uh one of them all
right all right okay look there's nothing to be
afraid of i mean we're not that different from you
at the end of the day we are tax paying gas
pumping american citizens just like you okay
let's not get carried away because people they
want someone who's stronger and generally better
than them in every single conceivable way after
all who else is going to save you but don't take
it from me take it from this guy hello america
as the original superhero i assure you that you
are in safe hands with us i'm soldier boy and i
approve this message god bless you soldier boy
translucent
blew him up in the ass man i'm gonna go
welcome back everyone it's charlie this is gonna
be my video for the boys season three teaser
trailer obviously there's some soldier boy stuff
in there and they're reminding you what's going
on with stormfront's character after the end of
season two so we'll break it all down there's a
bunch of easter eggs and we know a lot about
what's going on with the plot of season three
so if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i will keep
doing season 3 bonus videos while we wait for them
to start filming we'll do an amazon giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave all your predictions for the boys season
3 on the video and obviously spoiler warning for
everything in the boys season 2 episode 8 finale
because we'll be talking about everything
that happened and how it sets up season 3.
i'll number these as we go along just to stay
organized starting with the homelanders stuff
just reiterating his speech from the season 2
finale ending scene heroes are here to help you we
are here to help you and the stormfront scene with
aya cash reminding you that big spoiler warning
stormfront is not dead as the end of season 2.
aya cash will come back in the boys season 3 in
some fashion the showrunner was very clear about
this he got a lot of questions because there were
a bunch of interviews that they were doing with
the cast and crew the past couple of days he joked
that she was actually more like stumpf front now
than stormfront because she lost all of her limbs
but that's them just making her go full anakin
skywalker darth vader i hate you i have the high
ground and it's them just teasing that they can
mostly bring back near-dead supers in the comics
in no joke they can use massive doses of compound
v to fully revive ones that have been dead for a
long time it's just that they come back as
mindless zombies so they're like compound v
zombies basically i saw a lot of questions about
them doing payback references during season 3 from
the comics because if we're making star wars
darth vader jokes about stormfront the whole
idea of her payback team in the comics in star
wars the empire strikes back the empire and the
star wars universe are basically an allegory
for space nazis and she's literally a nazi
on the show but in the comics stormfront was a
member of the team called payback they're meant
to be an avengers marvel reference like payback
avenge revengers make all the thor jokes you want
has it got a name it's yeah it's called the
revenges revenges because i'm getting revenge
you're getting revenge and you're people what
are you on revenge but i know there are a lot
of questions about what will they actually do with
her character during the boys season three other
than show that she's getting a bunch of artificial
limbs like darth vader we have her in a secret
facility she will pay for what she's done which
does sound like a bit of a reference to payback
for those of you asking too about what her german
speech was as she lay there on the ground what was
she saying she was actually talking about a happy
memory that she had of her daughter chloe and her
husband friedrich vaught bat when her daughter was
still a young girl she's speaking to homelander
hallucinating thinking that he's really her dead
husband because she's so delirious with pain and
i'm paraphrasing but she says something like do
you remember the trip we took in the countryside
friedrich that day with chloe picking red apples
it was the first time chloe ever tasted an apple
that was a good day so it's her mind latching on
to this distant happy memory that she had of her
family before they died back during world war ii
before she had to come to america and adopt her
secret identity of liberty so even though she's
a terrible terrible person in the context of the
show and during season two it's just them
reminding you that at one point in time she
was happy she did have a family the only really
important characters for season three that they
don't feature in this teaser trailer though are
ryan himself and victoria newman the congresswoman
who's going to be running the department of
superhero affairs inside the government there
are a lot of you that have asked questions about
references to comic book vic newman because she is
a character from the comics but she's been gender
swapped and they've kind of changed her storyline
but also a lot of you are wondering if she's going
to be a reference to silver kinkade in the g-men
storyline from the boys comic book because silver
kinkade is a comic book character who has sort of
emma frost like abilities psychic abilities and
that's kind of the way they're using victoria
newman's powers the g-men are basically another
team that's sponsored by vaught in the comics
the one thing that does seem like a big comic
book easter egg though is hughie infiltrating
the office of superhero affairs like he tries
to get a job with her at the end of the season
and he does that during the g-men storyline in the
comics so they might just be pulling from all over
the place in the comics within the context of
the show though in season three hughie doesn't
think that he's infiltrating anything but like he
says he hasn't told the boys that he's inside that
office butcher will actually probably try to take
advantage of that because he's really only loyal
to himself like he's only protecting ryan because
it's fulfilling this promise that he made to his
wife becca the boys are kind of like his surrogate
family so you could say that he's loyal to them
but there's sort of neutral territory in
this giant war between the government and
superheroes and bot they hate bot and they kind
of hate the government too but in the comics
vic newman was the former ceo of vaude and
he's the current vice president of the united
states so i think they might be pulling
from that vic newman story line where she
used to have ties to vote so she secretly has
some sort of connection to them remember vots
whole thing edgar's whole thing is getting supers
in the white house controlling the government
vaught wants real power and in order to do that
you need to be able to control the government
and public policy so what better way to rig
that game than to control the person who's in
charge of the organization inside the government
that's responsible for regulating your company
then you have jensen ackles their soldier boy
chiming in at the end there in that scene we do
have some confirmed details about what's going on
with his character past and present obviously he's
a reference to captain america in the avengers
before stormfront came to the united states
during world war ii he was meant to be america's
first attempt to create a superhero but it went
terribly he's sort of like the worst version of
captain america you could imagine in the comics
he's a terrible soldier he doesn't know how to
use his abilities he winds up getting his entire
squad killed but in the context of the show it
sounds like they're actually going to be combining
both versions of soldier boy so there's actually
two versions in the comics there's the original
soldier boy from world war ii then there's one
in present day who's a little bit different
it sounds like they're going to combine aspects
of both of those characters into jensen ackle's
one version of soldier boy like we saw the statue
in front of the rally here this is what he looked
like during world war ii but supposedly during
season three he'll have survived the present day
so he will show up in the past in flashbacks
but also in present day and they'll explain
what he's been doing since world war ii just like
stormfront has been alive for a hundred plus years
for those of you wondering about herogasm 2 there
is some soldier boy stuff that goes on during
herogasm i won't say what happens because it's
super graphic and super wtf but the comic book
is out there if you want to go read it obviously
there's all the stuff that's going on with ryan
him slowly becoming what they hoped will be a
much better version of homelanders someday they
don't want him to turn into a psychopath like him
and then you have homelander just looking like he
went completely off the deep end on top of the
chrysler building just jerking off all over the
street make all the gross collateral damage jokes
about this scene that you want but if you have any
big questions about what was going on during
the finale or what's happening with season 3
as far as i know they're going to be filming early
next year if they hustle really hard hopefully
they'll be able to get episodes out by december
next year the mandalorian season two episodes are
gonna start premiering really soon i'll be doing
videos for that and then avengers wandavision
episodes also on disney plus later this year
i'll be doing videos for that too as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel you'll
see all those videos when they post everyone
click here for the boys season 2 episode 8 finale
video and click here for that brand new avengers
wandavision trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!